Many of my friends sing
the wonders of diversity.
I tried to tell them
diversity isn't a moral good,
but I end up looking like
some terrible racist.
Why isn't diversity moral good?
While diversity is our moral good,
but you can't,
diversity by race doesn't
produce diversity.
That's,
that's called racism.
That idea or diversity of gender doesn't
produce diversity unless that's how you
define diversity.
Look,
let's say that you get diversity
partly as a consequence of personality,
which is a good way of looking at it.
There is more diversity within
groups of people then between,
so like men and women differ to
some degree in their personalities,
but there's far more difference between
men within the male group and women
within the male group.
Then there is between the average
or typical male and female.
So it's a stupid wait.
Let's assume that what you want,
the organization's pursuing your complex
goal and you want a variety of skills
that would be suited to that goal.
Then you want there to be enough diversity
of ability within the group so that
the goal can be achieved
in a efficient and,
and uh,
and inexpensive manner.
Right?
Because what do you want
on efficient and expensive?
Obviously not.
So there's a presumption that you get
diversity by using identity politics
categories,
but there's absolutely no
evidence for that whatsoever.
So that's why diversity defined by race
or ethnicity or gender is not only not a
moral good,
it's actually a moral evil because it
dispenses with the whole idea of the
individual dispenses.
With the idea of competence.
It just replaces it with the assumption
that if you randomly select from the
population,
because that's how you
would get real equity,
you randomly select from the population
that that gives you the best qualified
group of people.
Well that's just,
that's,
you wouldn't do that
to select the plumber.
It's,
it's the stupidest possible way of
selecting for anything randomly,
you know,
there's no difference between selecting
randomly and selecting accidentally.
So it's moral diversity defined properly
is a moral good diversity based on
identity,
politics categories is a positive evil,
you know,
true to our,
our prime ministers.
Great example of that.
So back,
I think it was in 2015 he announced
that half of his cabinet was going to be
women because it was 2015 or something
like muddle headed virtue signaling,
signaling excuse for not thinking.
I think only 20% or 25% of
the elected mps were female.
So the proper balance on
average would it be 25% female,
75% male.
What he should've done
was figured out who,
what qualities would make for a competent
cabinet minister because it's actually
quite important to have competent cabinet
ministers and then selected from among
his people for nothing
other than competence.
But he could virtue signal and then
he set up the most important board,
let's say of the entire
comp country on it.
Cause I random basis Jesus,
how pathetic.
He should have been pilloried
by Canadians for that.
But we're so clued out and,
and also in this situation
that you described,
just like if I say,
well,
50% of Trudeau's cabinet
shouldn't have been women.
It's like,
oh,
you're a misogynist.
It's like,
no,
only 25% of the elected
officials were women.
Now you might say,
well,
it would be better if
50% of the were elected.
It's like,
maybe it would be better,
but it didn't happen.
So you can't,
you can't fix it at the top end.
It was appalling.
So it's a hard argument to make,
you know,
because you need to know that there's
more difference within groups then between
them in order to be able to come
up with a credible argument,
you know?
And then so yeah.